well the score really bugging the sends but uh
they're using every length possible that's a fly
Alex tuck has been battling everybody tonight
and now he's got a fly on his face last game
there was a fly that was not leave in between the
benches he was just hanging out that might be him
looking for a little attention I got away from
that fly people out there they saw that the F
it was a horse fly you got they're they're like
flies at a picnic man you just you got to keep
fighting them off or because they're not going
anywhere it's nice to know you take your family
out for picnics yeah she said we're trying to win
every night so yes I'm going to be tough on the
young guys but I also have to allow them to make
their mistakes and I can't come down on them too
hard it's a good se he is he is wired that's three
Red Bulls torch don't turn around Tor I saw that
guy in the elevator here he freaked me out even
then Pon loading up the one-time Brock besser now
it's fired in on a set play and he scores for
Hughes lots of movement off the puck and they
score again they're all having great starts and
a goal for Bessel as he bats it out of the air
drops it the pass the shot the goal here's kzco
skates in shoots and scores lafy oh score with
laferty and Suter and he scores and a one-time
sliding across Blackwood but it snuck through
Garland again boiler scores and now we're into
double digits as Anthony boiler has his second
tonight Mark Andre flurry is such a friendly guy
he's always talking and here we saw it live he
had a conversation during play with Jack Hughes
Jack was kind of in position keeping his eye on
Brock Faber and they're having a friendly chat
they're chuckling together there as the game
plays on The Young guarden the old guarden I'm
sure they were just saying hey I enjoy watching
you play vice versa keep it going kid something
along those lines just don't score yeah keep it
going but but not tonight and a good stick in CLA
as that was yoel Aria making the most of his time
look out turnover Mahan score it doesn't get any
easier than that Shan Mahan oops and it might have
that stop slide past taking advantage of a big
miscue by Aiden Hill Banger what's up baby how
you doing you're miked up oh yeah I am I guess
I am miked up I think we'll hear some more I
love that guy Point touch down the board shoots
l in the same the F in as it goes up in the air
as lafer is getting pushed into the goal tender
off LA's helmet that's the way to use your head
and Seth Jones breaks it up [__] denied in the
crease by solder Bloom Puck still alive kinsky
is there and [__] scores and then the play by
Boyd how does this Puck get back into the front
oh my goodness you believe that no it rolls up
the back of the net by the crossbar off the back
of the name plate of solder boom and in the net
consecutive shifts oh this one bounces in front
of cousins what do you know Nick cousins picks
up the loose change for the lead Joey dard goes
out of his net to play the puck takes a funny
bounce off the partition comes right out in
front and there's cousins he's coming right down
Main Street the way they're taught hang takes the
return pass it the backand sh scores nothing
play but jordano gets it with the tip of his
blade and tips it up and over the shoulder of
Joseph Walt here's M again first penalty over
out of the box Mavish TI to him short-handed score
Mason Mavish a short-handed goal with 12 seconds
left and the Ducks lead 43 unbelievable one of
the most amazing wins I have seen this team ever
get John Cy looking to open the scoring here at
Rogers Arena and fell down and he still got a
shot away but put it wide and that's going to
make the highlight reels for a while sometimes
you overthink things Foody has his eyes down on
the puck and right here his left skate catches a
rut but at this point you're just kind of trying
to get anything you can towards the goal tender
the stick handle the puck out an edge and misses
the net Brown drops it off gets it back great pass
hit the post Beacher had a golden opportunity and
a yawning net and he rang it off the iron looking
for his first NHL goal encouraging him to keep
firing away with Anton forsberg of the Ottawa
Senators and UK peka lugan come to ceriz for
the senator first ever golender ceremonial face
[Music] off and the knock it away bot for holla
for the hatrick he broke his stick you got to
be kidding me some Mis empty Nets poot feeding
Eric Holland with a sure hatrick and his stick
fails himot pushed out of the Zone it's coming
near the net and they score another Insurance
marker for the Calgary Flames into the corner
but T slides it up top of the town of his own
there's wood he'll race for it the puck going
toward an empty net and it scores is that Ross
Colton Colton has the puck there now goes to
Brock Nelson who then throws it out that's
going to be Colton's goal threw it all the way
down the ice last ABS player to touch the puck
gets credit for the goal something to watch here
jar broke his stick on that sequence so Chris lat
Tang has given him his stick down low for kale
Mar in front Dr jar player stick goalie glove
all the way across pass to the middle tro a shot
and it's at the goal line but did it cross no hit
the post stayed on the line there's a chance and
it's off Conor helb post and oh boy there's lots
of bodies heluk reacts heluk with his arm made
sure that crrider didn't get his stick on it 8
seconds left mccan out in front they score hey
hey what do you say Jordan Everly and the Kraken
win and a little kiss right on the helmet and the
Kraken with a huge win to start the road tripet
off cross rank Carlson one more anticipated by
fa juggled out of the air an amazing hand eye
coordination move from Milano he didn't convert
if that went in that would have been the goal
of the century cradle out of midair and then
whack it out of midair unbelievable and what a
stop unbelievable he's smiling at that play right
now in the NHL a wrist shot they score rust looks
gives it to pson back across they score here's
Brian rust they score and after it against kop
and they score in the attacking Zone to Malin
and he scores here's Crosby in a low drops it
for lat tang and he scores aari shoots safe they
score gensel to the net a backand by rust that's
too easy pass in front Smith doorstep bang bang
play Top Line on here rust at the net thrown a
battling for it the puck went in and Pittsburgh
have double digits it's 10-2 the Penguins put up
double digits on the scoreboard at sa Center keeps
it in again bunning ping that around Schultz and
dord will play it and now Carolina comes up with
his steal goami side of the neck round for Bunning
for nous they score duband blew a tire the court
was indecisive indirected it to him and duband
went heels to the ice he turns it over again again
to Robertson tries to catch up way out the Del and
the stars with pressure score the delovic was
way out from the play on Robertson and Harley
gets the goal into the bacon net overly aggressive
charge out by NAD delovic the net minder doesn't
get much on it barely got to it initially back for
splits on the PS and walks right got was ticking
wide wasar got to stick on that the puck goes up
and out oh you could tell as soon as he stepped
he had him empty net tala is down and out he's not
even close to this Puck more shots from oetkin he
is hungry he's gone four games with no goals and
you know what he we'll give him an assist for that
Maran again cross I coyo in front that's blocked
by kulakov it's under him Panthers are looking
for the whistle it's under kulakov finally we get
it what a tough play you got kulakov with the the
puck underneath them and he doesn't know where
it is and all he's doing is taking stabs sends
across D'Angelo holding back across NES wa scores
he does it again game over Marty NES he's got two
goals and three points on the night loving every
minute of it Jersey with a look to valami with
a shot bounces around did it go in oh it hit the
crossbar and hold on that's a penalty glove yeah
a might be a penalty shot here Tyson it's Baron
right there he saves the goal so it was the right
play to make Nick schaltz going wide score Mick
smz one nothing Arizona oh come on SMY give us a
smile slowly moves in BDI shoots against the post
and then went in off the quick and it counts it
hit the post so hard came right back hits quick
in the back back of the leg wow and gets past him
out to the top carry a shot off the backboard
did it go in almost a celebration for a moment
they threw the arms up nothing yet Campbell in
a full scramble trying to get the shot here's
O'Reilly score it's hatrick time Ryan O'Reilly see
I think he scored before that see I think it went
in initially so he actually scores twice on this
shift there's one oh it did go in they put it but
he never gives up he's like all right I'll get
the second one yeah you know what he was coming
in thinking shot and thinking score and then all
a sudden Riley came into him and I don't think
he realized that his stick just exploded watches
the play happen boom right there and it wasn't a
slash of any kind and just the delay of putting it
down brought the arm up Dylan will work it back at
[__] Ley Dodges a bump he gave it away mcpain
shoot sto by El scoring the rebound well this
one was a hairy Play Down Low from shley you're
not going to see Mark make this play very often
or this mistake as he's looking to get the puck
through the middle of the zone out to high ice
through the middle up to Anderson shot save made
rebound jled it fell behind but J it's loose taken
by the Stars it's somehow stayed out they will
ice it all the way down and what a carnival in
the Dallas crease Andre laughing it off this is
insane I mean this this is ludicrous I think he
makes the save behind his back it flips over top
of him he turns around oh he gets big time skate
save help from ASA Lindell far's got a ton of room
here down the left side into the Buffalo Zone pass
across goes off of Power I believe and in the
back of the net it's one nothing phly yeah that's
a tough break right there for the Buffalo Savers
is fairby and right there as he slides it across
it's going to deflect off Yogi Haru stick right up
and over the shoulder pulo in a play pulo One Stop
mon B got across well an entertaining overtime
but that won't settle anything as they'll go
to a shootout six three the shots in favor of the
golden ice there's a look at pangula what a setup
you can see his frustration chance he had the set
up from Stone that stick's no good he had a great
chance he just didn't Elevate the puck right he
had monteo credit to the goaler for getting across
well you don't see this all that often but there's
an area of the rink where go tenders can't go out
and handle the pck and late in the period it's
snowy the puck stopped markstrom had to retreat
his defenseman and uh Anderson felt that he was
going to go and play you could see how casual he
was in front he was surprised that rope hence got
to that puck uncontested ahead for Steven Lawrence
breaking in he'll shoot off rymer's glub off the
crossbar and it's in they score lomberg might have
poked it home off the glove of Rhymer it went
up and over top of him and had another velocity
off the crossbar off the back the pad and then in
the net right sett going to to get a penalty for
playing with his stick it broke his stick and
instead of dropping it he went and played and
kicked the puck up so markstrom gone to the bench
he tries to play it there that's not where he got
the penalty but you got to get rid of it now you
got to throw it away instead he kicks it and he
holds it and that's where the penalty came from
Anaheim has a bench Miner penalty for having six
men on the ice too many men so for most referees
it's too many men on the ice but for West it's six
men that's too many favor on defense gets a lot
of ice time from Dean Emon a steel here Hartman
Glides in alone Hartman forehand to backhand he
scores here's a play at the blue line there's a
play by farari trying to get that pu to the net
it's Mavish looking for vrono drops it back stro
holding shooting blocked off by Russ Brian Russ
sell it out for his team and keeps it 21 and now
jar a huge save on Str you got to love it how
about Brian rust rupper Tristan sorry I don't
know maybe a steak dinner maybe something even
better after that one final seconds ticking down
G drive it goes wide another centering feed
that wouldn't go it stays up just before the
horn how John Gibson in desperation Sid's like
he's looking up at the jump Tron what happened
right there what's going on here it says well I'm
not Michael Jordan care to explain the uh swag
today yeah we play soccer uh all time before game
like a warm up and um it was I think uh 5 years
ago dvo or somebody hit the ball too high and I
can't jump so I said like well I'm not Michael
Jordan you know and uh d uh give it to me this uh
hoodie and I'm still learning drops off spra cider
wman bar what a shot top shelf it's two2 halfway
through he looks like Brutus in papey where go
Jak